Hallo! Herzlich willkommen zur ersten Folge meines neuen Formats: Kikis Kitchen Hacks!
Heute zeige ich euch 8 Lebensmittel, die ihr eventuell sogar falsch lagert und wie ihr sie richtig lagert!
Kommen wir zum Lebensmittel Numero 1, das habt ihr wahrscheinlich alle Zuhause:
es handelt sich um Brot! Ich habe letztens bei einer Freundin gesehen: die hat ihr Brot
im Kühlschrank aufbewahrt und ich hab gedacht:"Nein, nein, nein, das geht nicht!"
Brot im Kühlschrank - ihr müsst euch vorstellen es sind Stärkemoleküle enthalten
und die geben Wasser ab. Das hört sich jetzt so wahnsinnig wissenschaftlich an
aber im Endeffekt ist für euch nur wichtig: das Brot wird richtig schnell alt und das ist mega schade!
Und ihr macht's am besten so, dass ihr euer Brot umfüllt von dieser Plastikverpackung in ganz normale Brottüten,
die ihr auch vom Bäcker kennt. Die Brottüten sind optimal denn die entziehen zwar
ein bisschen Feuchtigkeit, geben aber auch ein bisschen Luft ab.
Die Luft kann zirkulieren und: optimal!
Und so bewahrt ihr sie dann auf Zimmertemperatur auf, perfekte Temperatur ist übrigens 18-22° C.
Tipp Nummer 2!
Gewürze! Gewürze lagert ihr natürlich - das wisst ihr alle - schön luftdicht.
Ich habe dafür Vorratsdosen.
Und ganz ganz ganz wichtig: trocken und kühl lagern! Und ihr dürft nicht den Fehler machen
und das Ganze rüber verlagern unterm Herd! So wollte ich das nämlich erstmal,
habe mich dann umentschieden denn die Hitze vom Herd macht eure Gewürze schlimmstenfalls kaputt.
Punkt Nummer 3: wer kennt's nicht? Ich kannte das vor allem von früher als ich ein bisschen jünger war,
ich habe immer Petersilie da gehabt weil ich Petersilie eigentlich zu allem möglichen mag
aber es wurde mega schnell schlecht im Kühlschrank. Ich gebe euch jetzt den ultimativen Tipp:
lagert es genauso wie frische Blumen einfach in Wasser hochkant.
Also ihr steckt sie einfach rein, lasst sie dann auf Zimmertemperatur und so halten sie viel viel länger.
Das könnt ihr auch mit Dill machen, mit Schnittlauch, mit allem möglichen!
Bei Salatblättern mache ich's immer anders. Da verlangsame ich den "Faulprozess" sage ich mal
weil die auch nicht so lange halten.
Ich wasche sie ganz gut, trockne sie sehr gut ab und wickle sie dann ganz locker in ein sauberes Küchentuch
und gebe sie dann in den Kühlschrank und zwar ins untere Fach.
Tipp Nummero 4: wir machen jetzt Tomaten- und Paprikamark ein bisschen länger haltbar
weil es auch sehr gerne und sehr schnell schimmelt, ich kenne das zu gut! Und zwar nehme ich mir immer
Paprikamark in so großen Gläsern und da ist es wichtig, dass ihr jetzt einen Teigschaber nehmt und das Ganze
säubert und so weit wie möglich nach unten drückt, das mache ich jetzt als allererstes.
Und dann versiegelt ihr die Oberfläche mit Öl und zack, habt ihr wieder ein paar Wochen mehr Haltbarkeit!
Auf geht's zu Tipp Numero.. 5!
Also Käse haben wir immer im Kühlschrank. Immer, immer, immer, wir sind richtige Käsefreaks!
Und deshalb zeige ich euch mal, wie ich es früher aufbewahrt habe
und wie ihr das niemals aufbewahren dürft! Jetzt habe ich hier z.B. ganz normalen Scheibenkäse,
geb das hier in meine Frischhaltefolie und jetzt passiert folgendes:
der Käse kann nicht atmen, der fängt an zu schwitzen und zack, ist er weniger haltbar
und ihr müsst ihn sofort wegschmeißen.
Daher mein Tipp: nehmt Wachspapier, so kennt man das ja auch von Käsetheken.
Wachspapier locker einfach drum herum wickeln und dann damit's keine Gerüche annimmt
und trotzdem noch mal ein bisschen geschützt ist, in eine Frischhaltedose rein
und zack, ist euer Käse länger haltbar.
(H: Wachspapier ist jetzt kein Backpapier?)
Wachspapier ist kein Backpapier, genau.
(H: Ich dachte, das wäre das gleiche!)
Nein. *kichert*
Ganz anders wird jetzt Fetakäse z.B. gelagert oder Schafskäse oder Hirtenkäse, was auch immer!
Das lagert ihr nicht so wie den Goudakäse, den ich jetzt hier gerade haltbarer gemacht habe.
Ihr macht dafür eine Salzlake, die kommen ja auch in Salzlaken! Und dafür nehmt ihr einfach z.B. 1l Wasser
und 150g Salz, das ist eine 15-prozentige Salzlake. Das kocht ihr einmal auf  und lasst es vollständig abkühlen.
Und ich gebe das hier auch wieder in eine Frischhaltedose
und breche das jetzt hier in grobe Stücke, geb das rein und dann kommt das in den Kühlschrank
und hält so auch wieder viel viel länger.
Kommen wir zu Tipp Nummer 6! Und jetzt schreibt mir mal alle in die Kommentare: Wie lagert ihr Zitronen?
Jetzt, ich warte!
Habt ihr? Okay gut!
Ich lager sie immer im Kühlschrank, was sehr falsch ist! Ich mach's jetzt seit ein paar Monaten anders.
Ich musste das alles auch selbst erst lernen, das bekommt man ja nach und nach so mit!
Und ich lagere sie jetzt nur noch auf Zimmertemperatur denn so haben's Zitrusfrüchte am liebsten!
Daher einfach schön in einen Korb und ich muss auch sagen: die sehen ja auch schön aus!
Was sagst du denn Hamza?
Schön gelb, schön dekorativ...
(H: Schön frisch!)
Schön frisch! Hier noch ein paar Orangen dazu - perfekt!
So!
Tipp Numero 7! Es geht um zwei Best Friends: Tomaten und Gurken! Aber-
(H: *lacht* Die Best Friends beim Döner!)
Ja, beim Döner, beim Salat.. aber ich muss auch ehrlich sagen: die beiden vertragen sich gar nicht so gut,
wie wir immer alle dachten!
Die haben so ein bisschen Beef miteinander denn ihr dürft Tomaten und Gurken nicht zusammen lagern,
das habt ihr auch bestimmt schon gehört, das geht ja Gott sei Dank total rum!
Denn Tomaten stoßen das Gas Ethylen aus während sie nachreifen und das ist nicht förderlich für die Gurken.
Daher tue ich die mal ganz weit weg und zeige euch jetzt, wie ich Tomaten lagere.
Nicht im Kühlschrank: die Tomaten haben's bei ca 15° C am liebsten und: nicht übereinander gestapelt
sondern nebeneinander, dass sie auch viel Platz haben.
So, fertig!
Wir kommen zum allerletzten Tipp, zu Kartoffeln!
Ihr habt doch bestimmt alle Kartoffeln Zuhause!
Und falls ihr bis hierhin irgendeinen Tipp noch nicht kanntet,
dann schreibt's mir doch jetzt in die Kommentare!
Und bei Kartoffeln ist es so: die dürft ihr nicht in den Kühlschrank tun, das ist ganz klar.
Die dürfen aber auch nicht zu warm gelagert werden. Ja was macht man jetzt wenn es im Sommer draußen
warm ist und dann ist ja automatisch hier in den Schränken auch alles so ein bisschen warm?
Ideal wären tatsächlich 10° C, dennoch aber nicht im Kühlschrank weil der Kühlschrank zu feucht ist.
Deshalb mache ich es so - dann nimmt man das halt in Kauf, dass es im Sommer halt ein bisschen wärmer ist -
ich mache es so, dass ich sie entweder in so einem Standseiher mit Löchern
oder in so einer Kiste mit Löchern(findet ihr im Bürobedarf) dass ich sie da lagere,
damit sie auch genug Luft bekommen. Und dann gebe ich sie ganz einfach in den Schrank
dass es auch schön dunkel ist und ein bisschen kühler als wenn sie jetzt hier irgendwo auf Oberflächen stehen.
(H: Und deswegen habt ihr dieses Netz!)
Genau, die Supermärkte lagern ja auch von vornherein alles schon richtig.
Und das waren meine 8 Tipps! Die allererste Folge Kikis Kitchen Hacks, das war eine Basic Folge.
Falls ihr weitere Tipps und weitere Folgen sehen möchtet, dann hinterlasst mir unbedingt Feedback
damit ich auch weiß, ob euch das interessiert oder auch nicht. Und schreibt mir auf jeden Fall,
was ihr aus diesem Video mitgenommen habt und was ihr schon kanntet.
Und ansonsten würde ich mich natürlich freuen, wenn die zweite Folge auch bald kommt
und wenn ihr diesem Video ein kostenloses Abo hinterlasst, dann verpasst ihr nämlich auch nichts mehr!
Und dann sehen wir uns bei meinem nächsten Video! Ob's dann ein Rezept ist, ein Vlog
oder eine neue Folge Kikis Kitchen  Hacks, das bleibt noch im Verborgenen!
Das sehen wir dann beim nächsten Mal! Tschüss, eure Kiki!